[Music]  being a street dog isn't so bad at all  he's a chair I'm free to be whoever I  want to be walk wherever I want to walk  Hey hi are you two UH twins  I'm our husband pal aha eat whatever I  want to keep he's at remember I got this  the old-fashioned way I stole it  snob hell there we go I got my collar  let me just take a little guess here  you're the center of your peoples  universe right you could say that well  that's basically all over now you're  about to be replaced  replace me I don't think so lady this is  Lily  when the baby moves in the dog moves out  [Music]  help me get this thing off I'm sorry  this is not awkward at all  this way it's totally safe  we're not gonna do that keep it crazy  you'll know that happen  [Applause]  Wow  what is this place  but a great big world out there  with no fence around it  [Music]  every day could be an adventure  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]